first question is what would you do with
this place do you like what we have done
with this set what would you do to it
yeah I like I like all the color you
have in the clothing of your audience
that's I like that you leave the blinds
open to be a little risque yeah yeah
yeah actually it's a nice looking set if
you're very nice said it's a very warm
space I choose each audience member
personally before the show yeah why that
one
Oh we'll get into that later smite
that's my father there is so much to
talk about first of all this is such a
phenomenon congratulations on your
success how the property brothers get
started how did this happen oh man way
back in the day we we were actors as
kids and we didn't want to be struggling
actors so we thought let's get into real
estate let's let's pay for our own
productions and stuff like that
so we read everything we could about
real estate started a real estate
company fast forward 10 years and we
thought let's make a show about this and
and drew actually got cast first yeah
well I actually tried to get back into
acting because I missed it we originally
got in real estate to get so I could
fund our creative efforts and then I
started being pitched as a host I'm like
that's lame
I want to be an action superstar like
Tom Cruise you said being a host of a TV
show was lame after telling a crowd no
your crew when I was young and immature
now I am old that over-the-hill the
first show got drew like a spore was the
dumbest thing I've ever heard of it was
called realtor idols like American Idol
for realtors had a twin brother who was
awesome and they pitched just in a show
about what we were doing with clients
and that became property brothers so
right but you had a little trouble at
first you tried to pitch the show in
Canada and people were not happy
we actually pitched originally to HGTV
in the u.s. turned it down HDTV and
Canada turned it down then there's a
small network in Canada called The
Woman's Network and when they were
pitched the show the executive she
literally said these were her words
verbatim she's like two young hot guys
doing slow-motion renovations in tight
jeans we'll take that show and so we
aired it within three weeks with the top
show on the network Wow came to the US
and within another three months here
we've been the top show for ten years
now and that's fantastic welcome
[Applause]
we're looking for a sidekick ya know
I've I've often had the note wear looser
jeans anyway let's not dwell the veining
that's different you Jonathan to me or
especially you me we have the same
problem when you're this Celtic white
look it's like staring at the Sun over
your eyes look don't look at that that
is hello this is this is like the before
middle and after because this is what a
dude leg is supposed to look like let me
point out you just put your legs between
Conan's legs I feel ya let's call dream
it one night it happens the next day now
Jonathan you're the contractor okay you
do the work drew you're the broker now
sometimes people give you a hard time
because they say you don't do as much as
your brother I think you're the guy
who's on the phone this is work - yeah
we get that all originally with the
original show people all the time be
like oh my gosh I love the property
brothers oh you're the one that does no
work I'm like excuse me it's very hard
whenever you go excuse me you've lost
your argument our new show property
brothers forever home the reason we had
we have that in this show brother vs.
brother where we compete is because
Jonathan was sick of me not doing the
construction so we got him back in we're
back way back in the days so you got
understand you can't trust real estate
agents that's the first thing yeah we
licensed him as a real estate agent we
were doing our own flips and then we
what we would do is we do 50/50 of the
work each then we would sell the house
and split the profit 50/50 he quickly
discovered he could hire someone to do
all the labor for minimum wage then
still split the profit and take the
committed and make a purchase in the
sense so I was in there doing all the
work I'm like this is [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah you got a watch brother now yeah
pays to be an [ __ ] yeah
that's my old setting yeah yeah yeah
I'm glad you read my book now I've heard
that you're you're an alcohol yeah
alcoholic you're a what on the street is
you're a terrible terrible alcoholic and
this is an intervention no you're a
workaholic which is not as fun as an
[Applause]
[Laughter]
alcoholic that would be me
say one word when you know you're a
workaholic so we were in Paris a couple
years ago first time ever in Paris in
general we're out true did the Eiffel
Tower we are at the top of the Eiffel
Tower
and drew took a conference call because
the reception was good yeah that's how
bad it is no matter where we are they
went back their room every night they
were working on the computer like eight
o'clock they work all that way it's
perfect for me because she's my constant
reminder to slow the pace a little bit
enjoy some downtime with family and
friends but I like to work right and
Eiffel Tower cell service absolutely
amazing I will say we should all get one
the only reason I go to Paris is that we
should all have one